bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 12 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal ce
soir nous recevons pierre cojan
président de la fédération française du
bâtiment des yvelines bonsoir à vous
nous reviendrons avec vous dans quelques
instants sur le bilan de 2015 et les
perspectives de 2016 pour le bâtiment
dans notre département est tout de suite
cette information le cimetière avaler
favières d'elancourt va s'élargir le
nombre actuel de concessions n'étaient
plus suffisants pour faire face au
nombre d'inhumation qu'il enregistre
chaque année 55 en 2015 le jardin
cimetière a été inauguré ce matin en
présence d'élus de la ville et 400
nouvelles concessions sans nouvelles
cases de columbarium et 15 caves urnes
vont être construites sur ce terrain
situé près du cimetière actuel des
travaux vont s'étaler sur 5 ou 6 ans
pour un budget de 1 million cent mille
euros de quoi couvrir les besoins de la
ville pour les années futures écouter ce
cimetière a été voulue sous un angle
vraiment paysager c'est pas un cimetière
en tant que tel il n'y a pas du tout la
présentation d'un cimetière
c'est un jardin du souvenir voilà nous
l'avons voulu jardin du souvenir faut
que les gens se recueillent mais dans un
ensemble qu'il soit un ensemble vraiment
paysage est totalement paysage y les
familles souhaitent avoir un endroit qui
soit volant un endroit de repos et un
endroit de je peux pas dire de plaisir
mais un endroit qui soit agréable et à
l'initiative du conseil français du
culte musulman les lieux de culte était
interpellé à ouvrir leurs portes ce
week-end la most hid elancourt situé
dans la zone d'activités trapel en cours
depuis une quinzaine d'années a répondu
présentes à cette demande le public a pu
assister à des prières et poser des
questions un reportage signé mélanie
poké et patrick jacques de dixmude
musulmans une fois arrivé aux portes de
la mosquée avec son son pied droit et
des 10000 alice milla qui veut dire son
nom d'allah que nous adorons dieu pour
les musulmans c'est une première pour la
mosquée d'el en cours
comme de nombreux autres lieux de culte
musulman en france elle a tenu à
accueillir du public
on sent vraiment une curiosité de
découverte et on essaye du mieux que
l'on peut essayer de répondre à cette
curiosité ces échanges c'est vrai que le
climat actuel ne fait que renforcer
cette idée qu'il est nécessaire que l'on
se rencontre et que l'on explique pour
deux choses pour les non musulmans et
peut-être même pour les musulmans leur
expliquer le retour aux bases faire
découvrir les bases le fonctionnement
d'une prière dans ce lieu de culte qui
accueille jusqu'à 400 fidèles lors de la
prière du vendredi mais aussi répondre
aux nombreuses questions que se posent
les visiteurs une initiative appréciée
par les fidèles comme par le public
cette porte ouverte ça va permettre aux
gens qui connaissent pas vraiment les
prières qu'est ce qui se passe dans les
mosquées c'est nécessaire j'ai envie de
dire pour les musulmans qui sont gérées
les victimes collatérales de tout ça est
ce qui est un petit peu dommage c'est
que il n'y a pas assez de monde
en tout cas d'alain rencontre que c'est
cette population sur ces deux jours la
mosquée a accueilli environ 150
personnes
après cette première expérience
l'association cultuelle à l'ifv à
nouveau ouvrir ses portes
je vous disais il ya quelques instants
au plateau avec nos pierre cojan
président de la fédération française du
bâtiment des yvelines alors vous
organisé demain votre cérémonie des
voeux à versailles c'est un grand
événement un petit peu pourra commencer
cette année l'occasion de faire un bilan
de cette année à 2015 qui était
difficile pour le secteur du bâtiment
brésilien bas c'était déficit le plus
bas c'est difficile depuis 2008 on a du
mal à se sortir
bon on voit une embellie un peu sur 2016
j'espère que vous en profiter justement
les liant à la ligne mais 15 des lois
qui ont été votées à votre profil bas
des lois on est on a eu la loi de
pénibilité la fédération s'est battu on
a réussi à éliminer la fiche journalière
il ne reste pas moins le la pénibilité
de comptabilité et de la cotisation qui
s'y affairent donc ça sans limites a
remporté ces petites victoires mais il
reste comme surplus de charges pour ces
pôles métiers du bâtiment au niveau des
chantiers des commandes
c'est difficile pour les petites
entreprises du bâtiment oui parce
qu'actuellement en face de nous nous
avons des entreprises étrangères et qui
viennent qui seront pas les mêmes coûts
que nous on a des charges que et
qu'elles n'ont pas il ya les manoeuvres
détachées et la lassus à ce niveau là
c'est encore une victoire qu'on a eue
avec la loire semène qui a permis de
faire des contrôles sans cadre justement
à ces travailleurs qui en faisait pas
qu'ils devraient encadrer j'espère que
ça va se faire et avec une carte qui va
être d'identité qui va être attribuée
par la caisse des congés payés
espérons que ça ça arrive et ça ça nous
remette sur un plan d'égalité mais ça
relève un petit peu le mail trahi parce
qu'ils vont tous nos adhérents des
entreprises des artisans y meurent les
uns pour les autres c'est catastrophique
christ hamas qu il ya eu des
manifestations des patrons de petites et
moyennes entreprises et les nanas vous
en faisiez partie donc cesser les
actions prévues comme ça pour 2016 pour
2016 pas trop pour 2016 il ya un voyant
vert nous un bâtiment on voit rien du
tout il ya un aperçu peut-être dans
d'autres secteurs donc on espère
qu'après à terme ça va nous revenir chez
nous et comme je disais en 2016 savez
une année il n'y a pas d'élection donc c
est propice ces deux années où il ya des
élections c est toujours un frein ça
peut statu quo donc j'espère que ça va
être une embellie un petit peu pour nous
c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours parlé
tout à l'heure pour 2016 on appréciera
2010 est donc il faut rester un petit
peu 2007 c'est vrai qu'on veut changer
la tendance on sait pas donc on est sûrs
dans l'attende donc 2016 il ya un espoir
nous n'a rien pour l'instant
bon on y compte bien y participer on va
prendre le train en marche
quelles vont être un peu vos chevaux de
bataille pour 2016 les gros enjeu pour
la fédération du bâtiment base yvelines
et nationales aussi pour 2012 2016
nous on s'est rendu compte au niveau
maîtrise maintenant c'est que au niveau
de salariés il ya plus beaucoup de gens
dans la maîtrise dans l'encadrement que
dans la salle
là on vient de créer on a créé l'année
dernière dans le nôtre trois semaines
aux trois départements 91 sont 18 et 95
bac pro qui va qui l'encadraient on a
actuellement de vendre une dizaine de
jeunes qui qu'ici mais parce qu'on a
besoin de deux heures encadrées impôts
no no no no no salariés et on espère
bien l'année prochaine
la prochaine session la dizaine casas
dans les yvelines
on va se battre pour ça qu'on l'a créée
dans nos locaux parce qu'il faut il faut
s'adapter
on s'aperçoit que maintenant il veut on
aura de moins en moins de salariés
manuel et on a un gars l'encadrement
parce que beaucoup de nos artisans ont
recours aux entreprises et à jeurre et l
maddock de mettre plus l'accent sur la
maîtrise que sur la zac exactement j'ai
eu chaud
il faut se mettre à l'évidence et puis
il faut prendre semble donc c'est notre
choix de bataille ne vous attendez quoi
de la part du gouvernement un pour 2016
un de ces coups de pouce dans un petit
pot soit qui dit qu'il faut qu'ils
sortent un peu de ddd chantier
dans les collectivités c'est pour
l'instant il mettre toute la tout
l'argent dans leur fonctionnement
c'est sûr que vous annoncez importants
mais tout se dégradant dans les
bâtiments dans les routes et tout est là
après puis ça va attendre que c'est
encore pire à réparer donc il faudrait
qu'il fasse quelque chose
vous allez aussi demandé quelque chose
pour que pour que justement les
chantiers les petites entreprises n'est
plus besoin de recourir à spécifiquement
alain terrenne qu'on puisse créer
embaucher de nouveaux widgets sont pour
réembaucher tous les artisans mes
collègues aux petites entreprises pour
embaucher il faut savoir pouvoir
débaucher parce que quand ça marche bien
ça va toujours c'est quand ça marche pas
que c'est dur
donc les gens disent je vais embaucher
mais si demain ça va pas comment je vais
faire pour ça c'est un frein c'est un
gros frein c'est ça ne s'est pas dire
c'était quelques des années je pense que
il faudra faire quelque chose pour
assouplir sa à l'effort de flexibilité
pour nous c'est complètement l'art sera
également un élément peut-être moteur
pour l'année 2016 demain vous avez
justement il va intervenir en parlant de
l'art du chantier à versailles ça va est
aussi un élément important pour vous
dans les yvelines
oui parce que nous avons deux des médias
mignot qui le directeur culturel du
château de versailles
donc on a voulu j'ai voulu l'un de ses
voeux afin de le faire intervenir
il ne parle un peu de larmes quand on
parle de l'arbas c'est un peu l'artiste
un peu là l'artiste donc fait un film
dessus et comme ils ont refait le
pavillon dufour pour l'accueil des
visiteurs de versailles veut nous fait
un petit exposé donc ça devrait être
intéressant
très bien merci beaucoup pierre cojan
d'avoir accepté à venir 104 d'avoir
répondu logique question et en parlant
de veut justement les voeux de
voisins-le-bretonneux été programmée
vendredi dernier au centre sportif les
pyramides à cette occasion là mais rudy
de la commune alexandra rosetti annoncé
les projets pour l'année 2016 les grands
actes ce concerne le déploiement de la
fibre optique dont la ville
l'aménagement de la zone d'activités de
la remise le lancement d'une mutuelle du
village ainsi que la rénovation du
gymnase des pyramides
autre promesse de la femme politique les
impôts ne compteront pas à ton la
commune l'année
prochaine c'est la fin de cette édition
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve demain à 18 heures pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
en direct je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée